I certainly hope you dance
as well as you dress.
There's only one
way to find out.
♪ Let's dance ♪
♪ Put on your red shoes
and dance the blues ♪
You and I, we're not so
different, agent Argylle.
Little help?
-Hold on.
The book is phenomenal,
sweetie, but...
What happens next?
It's called a
cliffhanger, Mother.
Elly, it's
called a cop out.
Whoa, hey!
There's a cat in there.
Oh my God, you're
Elly freaking Conway.
[Announcer] Author of
"Argylle" series, Elly Conway!
I am such a fan!
Oh yeah?
What is it you do?
Espionage.
-Would you sign my book?
Here we go.
I love this book!
C'mon.
Who are these people?
-Real life spies.
Why would
they care about me?
Because you're a goddamn
fortune teller, Elly.
What you wrote in your
new book actually happened
and you kicked
a hornet's nest
you didn't even
know existed.
I'm in some really
big trouble, Mom.
Oh, so now you're
experimenting with drugs.
I want all assets
on them now.
I need her to write
the next chapter.
God, I hate that cat.
Yeah!
It's time for you to meet
the real agent Argylle.
Oh my God.
-Oh my God.
Oh.
-My.
God.